voilà qui tranche avec la proche
occidentales hostiles envers moscou
l'approchent année cale entre deux pays
dits émergents la russie et la chine
rien à voir avec son récent entretien
avec joe biden bladimir poutine a changé
par vidéo conférence avec son homologue
chinois xi jinping et lui a assuré de sa
présence aux jo d'hiver de pékin on va
retrouver maylis destrée à moscou
bonjour maylis alors est-ce que vous
avez plus d'informations sur la teneur
des pourparlers du jour
l'importance des relations bilatérales
entre moscou et pékin lors de leur
rencontre les deux chefs d'état ont mis
l'accent sur cet aspect majeur vladimir
poutine s'est félicité de l'état de ses
relations ainsi que des échanges
commerciaux entre les deux pays qui ont
atteint 123 milliards de dollars sur la
période de janvier à novembre il a en
outre mis en exergue la coopération
russo-chinoise dans la lutte contre la
pandémie de coronavirus
les deux pires ont mis en place ce
nouveau modèle de coopération qui se
base sur les sujets comme la non j'ai
ans aux affaires internes aussi bien que
le respect mutuel des deux parties et
nous avons décidé de transformer est les
frontières on
ceinture de l'amitié qui me permet de
renforcer les relations commerciales
et le chiffre d'affaires a augmenté de
31 pour cent jusqu'à 123 milliards de
dollars ce qui nous a permis de dire où
nous avons
dépassé le record avant les pandémies
par rapport à 2010 9,1 et comme nous
sommes convenus nous allons dépasser
bientôt le niveau de 200 milliards de
dollars et nous sommes en train de
réaliser des projets d'envergure dans
l'agriculture et dans le domaine de
haute technologie et dès le début de la
pandémie nous avons réuni nos efforts
visant à abattre l'infection à virus est
et la chine devient le centre
international de production des vaccins
russey spoutnik des expos et nick knight
nous avons signé les contrats qui permet
de produire plus de 150 millions de
doses à part les efforts de six
fabricants chinois lui remercié son
homologue russe s'être opposé aux
tentatives extérieure visant à semer la
discorde entre moscou et pékin d'après
le chef d'état chinois
les relations entre les deux pays ont
prouvé leur résilience
vous soutenez les efforts de la chine
pour protéger ses intérêts nationaux clé
vous avez été opposés à des tentatives
de
créer des problèmes entre nos deux pays
je j'ai apprécié notre relation je suis
prêt à faire le bilan de cette année
a dressé la liste de nos projets pour
renforcer notre coopération dans divers
domaines
pour les intérêts d'une coopération
durable de très haute qualité dans nos
relations nous voyons qu'il ya des
processus
internationaux et de la pandémie qui
sont très intéressants sont
interconnectés le monde a commencé cette
ère de la turbulence notre coopération
russo chinoise a surmonté des épreuves
et s'est montré vite à cieszyn ping a
également insisté sur le lien fort entre
la russie et la chine en matière de
coopération sportive y compris en
refusant de politiser le sport
casimir poutine a confirmé sa visite en
chine en février à l'occasion des jeux
olympiques de pékin en entretien d'une
heure et demie bien remplie donc entre
des amis et des états alliés pour
reprendre les termes du kremlin
merci beaucoup à vous mais les extraits
pour toutes ces précisions en direct
depuis moscou fin